at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by audible audible
provides an unbeatable selection of
audio books including bestsellers how-to
mysteries thrillers memoirs and more
I've used audible for many years and I
have a few audio books to recommend
right off the bat number one ready
player one by Ernest Cline so listen to
the book that caught the attention of
Spielberg enough to get made into a
major film the writing is fantastic the
Tao Seneca by Seneca the younger this is
a collection of letters my favorite
compilation of letters of all time that
I've recommended the most of all the
books I've ever read and the graveyard
book by Neil Gaiman this is the fiction
book that I used to convert nonfiction
purists into fiction lovers I like the
version that Neil reads himself but
that's just me he is a hypnotic voice I
also recently enjoyed nonviolent
communication by Marshall Rosenberg
which was recommended to me by
best-selling author and Neil Strauss
make sure to get the audiobook version
and you will recognize it by the peace
sign on the cover and as an audible
subscriber you can choose three titles
every month one audiobook and two
audible originals you can't hear
anywhere else and there's some really
really cool stuff among the audible
originals you can listen on any device
anytime anywhere at home at the gym
while you're cooking on your commute or
wherever I often listen to audiobooks
when I'm walking my pooch or on the way
to the gym so on and so forth you'll
also enjoy easy audio book exchanges in
other words if you don't like what you
buy and you're like I've buyer's remorse
you can swap it rollover credits so if
you don't use credits and give it a
month they roll over into the next and
an audiobook library you keep forever
even if you cancel this last part is
important unlike say a streaming or
rental service with audible you own your
books even if you cancel your membership
and right now for a limited time you can
get three
months of audible for just 695 a month
that's 6.95 a month and that is also
more than half off the regular price so
give yourself the gift of listening and
while you're at it think about giving
the gift of audible to someone on your
list for more go to audible.com forward
slash tim t IM that is audible com
forward slash Tim or text tim t IM to
500 500 i get asked all the time if you
could only use one supplement what would
it be and my answer is inevitably
athletic greens it is your all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
in the 4-hour body did not get paid for
that and I travel with it to avoid
getting sick I take it in the mornings
to ensure optimal performance it just
covers all my bases if I can't get what
I need through whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day if you
want to give athletic greens to try they
are offering a free 20 count travel pack
for first-time users I always travel
with at least three or four of these
this represents a $100 value so if you
buy athletic greens you get an extra
$100 and free product so check it out
athletic greens comm forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens comm
forward slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase well hello ladies
and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to tease
out the habits routines favorite books
life lessons and so on
from world-class performers of all
different stripes and my guest today is
Andrew Weil MD otherwise known as dr.
while he is a world-renowned leader and
pioneer in the field of integrative
medicine and we've had a chance to spend
some time together over the last few
years and we dig in to some very fun
stories Andrew was born in Philadelphia
in 1942 he received a degree in biology
/ botany from Harvard College in 1964
and an MD from Harvard Medical School in
1968 after completing a medical
internship at Mount Zion Hospital in San
Francisco he worked a year with the
National Institute of Mental Health
then wrote his first book the natural
mind from 1971 to 75 as a fellow of the
Institute of current world affairs dr.
Weil traveled widely in North and South
America and Africa collecting
information on drug use and other
cultures medicinal plants and
alternative methods of treating disease
from 1971 to 1984 he was on the research
staff of the harvard botanical museum
and conducted investigations of
medicinal and psychoactive plants we
spent quite a bit of time talking about
that
dr. wall is the founder and director of
the University of Arizona Center for
Integrative Medicine where he also holds
the Louisville Jones endowed chair in
integrative Rheumatology and his
clinical professor of medicine and
professor of public health through its
fellowship and integrative medicine and
residency curricula the Center is now
training doctors and nurse practitioners
around the world
dr. wall is the editorial director of
the popular website dr. wild calm a
regular guest on video programs on PBS
and the author of 15 books my god I've
barely done five I don't know how one
can do 15 it's a lot including
bestsellers such as eight weeks to
optimum health
spontaneous happiness mind over meds
fast food good food and healthy aging he
can be found on Facebook
at facebook.com forward slash dr. Weil
and on Twitter at dr. Weil
so without further ado please enjoy a
very wide-ranging and often hysterical
conversation with dr. Weil dr. Worrell
welcome to the show thank you I'm very
happy to be here I am thrilled to
finally have you on the podcast because
I it gives us a chance to also catch up
I have not had the opportunity to hear
your latest and greatest adventures in
quite some time and some of the memories
that I have of the interactions we've
had and I have to thank Kevin Rose I
think initially for making that
connection relate to your incredible
gardens and plants so I thought that a a
logical place to begin this conversation
might be discussing your love affair
with plants can you talk about how this
started I think it started with my
mother when I was a kid and she got that
from her mother who had a real green
thumb so I grew up in a row house in
Philadelphia we had very little ground
behind the house but my mother and I
used to plant all sorts of seeds and I
grew but flowering bulbs indoors so that
started my interest and then as an
undergraduate at Harvard
I majored in botany which was a very
unusual major in a very old-fashioned in
those days but I had the good fortune to
have as a mentor Richard shultiess the
director of the Harvard botanical museum
who is considered the Godfather of
modern ethnobotany he had spent 14 years
in the Amazon was and one of his
interest was hallucinogenic plants so
studying with him got me interested in
medicinal plants and that really became
a career interest and I I always dreamed
of having big enough space to grow a
real garden and I now have that both in
Tucson where I live in the winter and in
British Columbia or AM in the summer so
I grow a lot of my own food I grow
flowers that all that gives me a great
deal of pleasure are there any
particular go-to
plants let's just say in in either of
those places perhaps they're different
just based on the climates that you use
on a on an ongoing daily or weekly basis
for food or for other health purposes
well in terms of foods I just say
there's nothing like having fresh fruit
from the garden and I'm a very avid home
cook I like simple dishes that are easy
to prepare and many people who eat my
food say they've never tasted such good
food well the secret is that it's fresh
food and I think many people have never
tasted plants plant foods that come
right out of the garden in terms of
medicinal plants probably one of my
go-to zzz's garlic I grow my own garlic
and garlic has many health benefits it's
a very powerful antibiotic it lowers
cholesterol blood pressure many uses and
you got to use it fresh and raw anything
you do to garlic lowers its medicinal
properties mmm you mentioned shultiess a
moment ago and give give a snapshot of
your history with plants can you put the
following in sort of chronological order
the the book doors of perception nutmeg
and cannabis in terms of of your
interest what is the proper order of
those three doors of perception first
that was written by Aldous Huxley I not
exactly sure the date but he came to MIT
to give a series of lectures on states
of consciousness or visionary experience
and that I remember was in 1960 and I
was a freshman at Harvard and I listened
to his lectures on radio and that really
inspired me to take mescaline which he
had written about in doors of perception
so I wrote him and asked him how do I
get mescaline and he wrote back and gave
me the name of a lab in New York I wrote
to them but they wanted all sorts of
paperwork and I found another company
that would sell it no questions asked
this was in the days before thalidomide
and the FDA did not require there
weren't many regulations on getting
drugs for experimental use anyway
cages of mescaline arrived outside my
door and who ordered delivery
yes and so in 1960 never having smoked
pot or really experimented with any
psychedelics I took mescaline a number
of friends and I did it several times
and I didn't really have a context in
which to put it you know I didn't know
people who were using psychedelics
nonetheless it showed me possibilities
which I wasn't really prepared to follow
at that time I think if I had I would
never have gone to medical school so
Aldous Huxley doors of perception came
first under schulthise - I opted to get
an honours degree in botany which is
part of the biology department I had to
write a thesis for that so the thesis I
wrote was on nutmeg as a narcotic nutmeg
is is a psychoactive drug if you take
enough of it and it was being used
mostly by people who couldn't get better
drugs such as prisoners you have to take
a whole can of powdered nutmeg I don't
recommend that or maybe one or two whole
nutmegs it it's pretty hard to choke it
down and you you do get high on it but
that's I'd say it's a pretty third-rate
high any rate I wrote that paper it got
picked up by a lot of people including
tabloids talking about people getting
high on nutmeg so that was really my
first academic paper then what was the
third book that you asked the mountain
oh no it was the this the second well I
suppose the third if we count mescaline
third of this the compounds or plants
which would be cannabis so back in those
days in the early 1960s I didn't know
people who smoked cannabis and I'd
really try it till 1964 when I was a
senior in college I didn't get any
effect from it then I went to Harvard
Medical School and I began using it and
having you know very enjoyable highs
from it it amazed me that as cannabis
was getting a lot of attention and
causing a lot of controversy there had
been no research done with it
really nothing astonishing there had
been one series of one experiment done
in 1937 I think but since then nobody
had given marijuana to human beings to
see what
did so as a senior in medical school I
devoted my elective time to research to
try to do the first human control
double-blind studies with marijuana I
can't even begin to tell you what a
challenge that was many people bet me
that there was no way I'd get permission
that meant coordinating the Federal
Bureau of Narcotics the Massachusetts
state authorities the universities
nonetheless I did it I gave marijuana to
human subjects and published this as a
lead story in science in 1968 it was
front-page news on The New York Times it
concluded that marijuana was a
relatively mild and toxicant I showed
that it did not dilate pupils cops were
arresting people who had dilated eyes
and said that was probable cause for
searching him for marijuana show that
didn't lower blood sugar which was often
invoked as the cause for the munchies
and that while in people who'd never had
it before you could demonstrate some
impairment on basic psychological and
psychomotor tests if you gave it to
people who were experienced with it you
couldn't really show anything like that
so the basic conclusion was relatively
mild and toxic and I thought that that
pot would be legal in five years boy was
I wrong yeah I thought it was just a
matter of getting the right information
out there I quickly learned that people
believe what they want to believe and
don't believe what they don't want to
believe now this is best this is a
perfect segue in terms of belief and
expectation because my understanding is
that one of the just in doing some
homework for this one of the challenges
of the experimental design and I don't
know if it was the IRB or maybe a
different acronym at the time for
putting this study into practice was
working with night naive subjects people
who had not had any exposure could you
talk about why that's that was important
to you because I wanted to see what
marijuana did in people that had no
expectations of what it would do my
intuition told me that what you expected
of pot and altar
and the setting in which you took it
where as important as the drug itself so
this idea that drug effects are a
combined effect of drug set and setting
I think is a basic to understanding how
mind-altering drugs work and with
marijuana where the the physical effects
are really relatively subtle there is I
think you really have to learn to get
high on it you have to associate an
altered state with it so it was very
important to me to use people who have
never had it that became a great
sticking point with the two universities
Boston University and Harvard that had
to give approval for this because their
fear was that if you introduced people
to this drug they would soon be heroin
addicts in the street anyway finally got
permission to move in I'll tell you one
funny story the the cops who were
involved in this the Federal Bureau of
Narcotics this was the old Treasury
Department cops and the Massachusetts
cops kept bugging me to come down to our
lab and watch people so on because
they've never seen anyone sniffing and I
said look we can't have you there
because that would be a major
disturbance of set and setting but I
said if they were patient and we had
time we'd do a demo for them at the end
when the experiments were finished so
one night we had two of my you know
friends who were labeled chronic users
of marijuana agreed to smoke it in our
laboratory and this bunch of guys too
from the Federal Bureau of Narcotics and
they were two from Massachusetts came
and these people they had the smoke two
of these joints that we had rolled it
was relatively mild by today's standards
and they smoked them and then we were
giving them these tests so the one cop
sidles up to me and elbows me and says
you know when is it gonna happen and I
knew what he was after I said what do
you mean he said you know when when once
when when doesn't happen and I said what
do you mean he said well when did they
get high and I said well they are high
and he said no no he said when did they
you know where to get high I don't know
what his ripping off their clothes
running around screaming but he really
knew guys just sitting there you know
doing their pursuit rotor tests and the
numerical tests and they weren't any
different that was a very sobering
experience for these law enforcement
agents
you know over this and at that time and
since many people would ask me how can
you tell if a person is high and I said
that you really can't unless they
volunteer that information you know
maybe their whites of their eyes are red
but nothing else that that was very
upsetting to many people so after I
published that study I was in great
demand as an expert on cannabis this was
in you know 1969 1970 1971 and I was
asked to testify about it in front of
Congress and be an expert witness in
various things and give lectures I made
it a rule for myself that I would never
do that unless I was stoned so I would
always smoke pot like I should say by
the way it's you know while I was a
fairly serious user of pot in my 20s and
30s I have had not been much of a user
of it and later in life but anyway it
was fun to do that and also to be in a
position where I be lecturing or
testifying and people would ask that
question how can you tell if a person is
high on pot and I would say you can't
unless they volunteer that information
of course I did not volunteer that I was
high on pot all right I've so many I
have so many follow-up questions here
the I want to rewind for a second
because I think these two might be
related can you describe your first
mescaline experience was it as what is
that
was it a Huxley like explosion
anaesthetic it was as far from it as
you'd imagine I was in a dorm room at
Harvard in this old dilapidated building
collaborative all it was on a Saturday
afternoon and I and one other roommate
of mine took it we took a half a gram of
pure mescaline and there was about seven
people sitting around watching to see
what would happen before they decided
whether they wanted to try it or not so
you know I about I didn't feel anything
for a long time and after maybe an hour
and a half I began to feel some physical
effects you know I just felt a little I
didn't know how to the drug experience
I'd had up to that point was with
alcohol and so that was the only I could
compare it to so I felt a little
different at that moment exactly the
phone rang and it was my mother calling
Philadelphia we never tiny we never
talked except on Sundays we would call
and I call my parents so she called and
said what are you doing and I said well
I'm just sitting around with some
friends and she said why aren't you
outside and I said well it's you know
I'm just sitting here and she said I
hope you're not doing anything foolish
like taking mescaline or anything like
that
now I I had mentioned the word mescaline
at the dinner table maybe three months
before and said I was interested I got
such a reaction from my parents that I
never said another word about it
there'd been an article in the newspaper
about a kid I supposed to leave him an
overdose of it so talk about you know
mothers being psychic I said oh no
mother of course wouldn't be doing
anything like that so that kind of
affected my my experience but I really
had no significant psychological change
from that time the second time I took it
I did have a very profound altered state
and it's hard to describe but I have a
real sense of oneness of everything and
a much larger reality out there that I
had been aware of and I think I had to
put that in a kind of box and tie it up
because if I had followed that I don't
think I would been able to stay in
school and get a medical degree so I
just boxed that up until I had a chance
to explore that I think we will come
back to the the exploration you
mentioned one thing in passing that I
wanted to just follow up on since I know
people are probably wondering and that
is you mentioned you used to be a heavy
or a consistent cannabis user not so
much so in your more recent years why
why has that changed you know I found
that my experiences with it changed over
time and in when I first was using it in
my I would say in my you know mid 20s my
the highs that I had with it were light
bubbly hysterical a lot of laughing you
know sitting around with with people
sentence sensual enjoyment of food and
music and all that after several years
of that I think
the highs changed for me I was using it
more heavily but the highs changed for
me to be more introspective and it was
in that period that I think it really
stimulated my imagination it was great
for writing my first book the natural
mind that I wrote in I wrote it in 1971
was published in 72 about drugs and
altered states you know I think a lot of
that felt channeled as a result of being
in the states of consciousness that
cannabis I'll shoot me in two so there
was a period I think of it then I was
living in South America for for a number
of years I used pot pretty regularly and
during that time I think the experience
has changed more direction of being more
sedative and it would tend to make me
groggy and not creative and imaginative
and that went on for a long time and you
know I finally just felt that didn't do
much for me so I leaned myself off it
which took some doing and then I began
to use it just occasionally with friends
as a social thing so now I just I
personally don't like the effect of it
very much so I think my body has changed
my brain has changed it was a real ally
for me in the early part of my life now
I'm more interested in an edit for its
medicinal uses and you know of course
I'm delighted to see our society finally
coming to some sensible terms with that
plant we are going to get to South
America because I have I've have
certainly a number of questions about
about South America but before we get to
that you mentioned set and setting for
people who don't know what that means
and I think you you you describe it in
briefs or could could you explain what
that means and can you also explain how
you first came across that phrase
because you you are you're at Harvard at
a very interesting time yeah well
Timothy Leary was there and Richard
Alpert and I one of my other mentors
besides Shull T's was a Freudian
psychoanalyst named Norman Zinberg we
became very close friends he was a
colleague of mine in the marijuana
research we got high together he was
older than me he was but a great
connection and he was one of
I think Leary was one of the first
people I heard used the phrase sentence
setting and Zinberg wrote about this a
lot in his academic writing so set is a
psychologists term for all of the
expectation that a person brings to an
experience and so when you know the
effects of drugs are not just due to the
drug I mean one factor is the nature of
the drug the dose but then there is what
a person expects to happen when he takes
that he or she takes that dose and then
there is the setting which is the
environment the physical and social
environment in which the drug is taken
and my experience has been is that the
combined effects of set and setting can
actually reverse the pharmacological
effect of drugs that you can give a
stimulant to a person in conditions of
set and setting that cause the person to
fall asleep and you give a sedative drug
to somebody under conditions of set and
setting that cause a person to become
alert and stimulated and this doesn't
just apply to marijuana and drugs I
think this has an awful lot to do with
medicine and healing as well I think
that the way we present treatments to
people and their effects also are very
dependent on expectation and environment
and it's the expectation both of the the
giver of the treatment or the drug and
the person who takes it in the early
days of LSD research this is you know
back in the in the late 50s early 60s
there was very good research being done
with it in terminal cancer patients for
example showing that people near the end
of life if they had a structured LSD
session and then follow up with a
skilled person had much less pain
required far fewer opioids had much more
productive interactions with family and
friends and much easier deaths people
got excited about that research and then
other people who didn't understand that
setting drug interaction and thought the
magic was just in the LSD tried to
reproduce that by giving LSD to people
without paying attention to set and
setting and they didn't get the same
results and that's one of the reasons I
think people backed off from from doing
research with it mm-hmm
how would you how would you suggest
people these days think about designing
studies for researching these compounds
because as you are certainly extremely
aware there are some incredible
challenges with studying let's just take
whether we want to call them
psychedelics or hallucinogens as an
example in terms of trying to placebo
control and some people will use niacin
or some type of lower dose as an active
placebo there's a great piece in the New
York Times just in the last few weeks
called what if the placebo effect isn't
a trick
looking at the biochemical basis and it
just gets the further down that rabbit
hole you go the more you realize how
incredibly challenging it is to design a
study that somehow isolates if that's
even the objective the the effects
particularly when you had to do that
that's worth doing Tim you know I think
really what we're going for is how D
maximally increase the chance of
producing a positive experience
no I'm fascinated with the potential of
these drugs in for healing in medicine
not just psychological problems but you
know real things like autoimmune
diseases cancer I think there's a
tremendous potential for these
psychedelics especially to give people
the experience that they can change
whatever is going on in their body I'll
give you one example that I'll give you
a couple that I've written about in when
I was about 28 right before I left for
South America it started was starting to
practice yoga and I had problems with
some poses the one I had the most
difficulty with is the plough where you
lie on your back and try to touch your
toes to the ground behind your head I
got so I could get my toes about a foot
from the ground and I couldn't go any
further I had excruciating pain in my
neck so I I was about to give up I
thought I was just too old to be doing
this at 28 and one day I was a spring
day I was living in Virginia I took LSD
with some friends outdoors a most
fabulous it was in a fabulous state my
body felt totally elastic I thought gee
while I'm feeling this way you ought to
try to do that so I lay on the ground
brought my toes down and I thought I had
about a foot to go and they
touched the ground and I didn't have any
pain and I kept doing it over and over I
thought this is fantastic the next day I
tried to do it I could get my toes about
a foot from the ground when there was
excruciating pain in my neck but it was
now different because I had seen it was
possible if I had not had that
experience I don't think I would have
been motivated to continue to practice
but knowing that I kept at it and in a
few weeks I was able to do it to me
that's a model of what these drugs can
do they can show you possibilities that
you wouldn't have believed but then it's
up to you to figure out how to have that
more of the time that's and I love that
example because it's it's parallel with
many experiences people would tend to
put into the box of psychological or
emotional in the sense that you have
someone like Sam Harris very smart guy
who came to meditation through seeing
what was possible via certain
psychedelic experiences I came across
your name very unexpectedly at a at the
home of a friend's parents and I was
browsing their bookshelf and I came
across a book with the very appealing
title to me at least of wizard of the
upper Amazon ah and I I was astonished I
hadn't come across this book before and
you wrote I think I don't recall if it
was the foreword or the introduction to
that book I wrote yeah yep and I became
really engrossed in this which was a bit
of a problem because I was supposed to
be at a party being social but I kept it
in the guest bedroom reading part of
this book
can you explain what drew you to South
America why did you go how long were you
there what did you do when you were
there
well schulte sent me there you know as I
said he had really lived there he lived
in the Amazon continuously from 1939 to
1953 and he'd had he had great
connections especially in Colombia so he
wanted me to go down there and I was
interested in studying coca leaves
especially but a whole range of plants
so are you interested in coca
specifically because he got me
interested in he said he had chewed it
every day during the time he was in the
Amazon and he recommended I go down
there I just liked the name
minute seems like something as before
cocaine was around and up here so I
wrote the natural mind sent it off to
the publisher and I got a fantastic
fellowship from a group called the
Institute of current world affairs that
sent people far and wide and all you
have to do is write a monthly newsletter
for them most most people did this on
political subjects and I had proposed
them writing about altered states of
consciousness and psychoactive drugs and
things like that and they've never done
anything like that and so I got this
great fellowship that paid all my
expenses I had that for three and a half
years so I first went to Mexico lived
there for three months to learn Spanish
which I did just by living with people
and having to speak Spanish and then I
drove my Land Rover all the way to
Colombia and that's an exciting trip it
was exciting took a while anyway and
then I spent about three and a half
years in South America mostly in
Colombia which I country I love but also
Ecuador Peru some in Brazil I saw a lot
of interesting things I learned a lot
about plant medicine I spent time with
shamans some of which were a very mixed
bag I mean there were drunks who just
wanted to be paid for giving people
ayahuasca you know I saw a few real
genuine healers I saw a lot of
interesting alternative medical stuff
anyway it was it was a very interesting
period of time in my life and I still
retain that connection I look forward to
going back and spending more time in
Colombia so I learned a lot of stuff but
interestingly I had been most interested
in finding healers and the when I at the
end of that time my car I came back to
the US I was just gonna be here briefly
and go back down to Mexico and the Land
Rover agency that overhauled the car in
Laguna Beach forgot to pack one of the
wheels with grease and I drove through
Tucson I was just gonna get supplies and
the wheel bearings shattered and took
six weeks to get a replacement it was
February a very
warm wet winter the desert was in full
bloom I met people I liked and I never
left and Here I am 45 years later still
living in Tucson it turned out that the
most fascinating healer the person I had
most to learn from was in Tucson and had
been here all the time
before I had gone down to South America
and there's something perfect about that
too that you know this going all this
wandering and then right under your feet
is what you're looking for it was an old
osteopathic physician named Robert
Fulford who was a master of cranial
therapy and the best healer I've ever
seen he just put his hands on you and
remarkable things happened he really
made me aware of the healing power of
nature you know he used to it felt so
good to be worked on by him and people
say when should I come back and he say
you don't need to come back you're fixed
and he would say you know all you have
to do is make these little adjustments
and let old Mother Nature do her work he
charged thirty-five dollars for a visit
use no equipment it was a very
inspirational to spend time with him did
he have anything in common with the as
you mentioned few genuine healers you
came across in your travels in South
America or there were there any
commonalities you know I think Fulford
used a modality cranial therapy which i
think is terrific I'm a big fan of
osteopathic manipulation that's
wonderful and and it's unfortunately a
very small percentage of osteopaths do
that anymore and fewer do really good
cranial therapy I think Fulford was a
healer and if he'd been working in some
other means he would be as effective so
I think I've met people who are able to
catalyze that and other people maybe
just by their own presence by their own
energy people who are whole and healed
themselves that by the way goes back to
your question about structuring research
with psychedelics I think the key thing
is that the person running the show
who's giving the drugs himself or
herself has to be fully experienced I
mean they have to be a shaman this is
what shamans are trained to do and you
can't just have research hacks trying to
give these drugs in clinical settings
and expecting to get no wonderful
results yeah yeah it's
even within the clinical setting of
course there's a huge I mean the
enormous range of experience right so
you could have someone coming in fresh
off the boat so to speak or you could
have someone like Mary Cusumano at Johns
Hopkins who's incredible and has just a
library of vast experience you mentioned
Salty's a name I'm very fond of and he
he put out a book I believe it was maybe
co-authored or just featured an
introduction with Albert Hofmann called
plants of the Gods yep which is a
fantastic book you put out a book that
as I understand it had I'm thinking of a
senator in particular mixed mixed
responses that I'd love for you to talk
about a little bit called chocolate to
morphine
subtitle understanding mind active drugs
why is why did you write book oh yeah
before I do that let me ask you did you
ever see another book that Schulte spoke
out which is a real collector's item you
remember the little golden guides I did
well he did a little golden kind of
hallucinogenic plants if you can find a
copy of it it's amazing
I mean it's every hallucinogenic plant
it done in that same style of minerals
and birds and and plants and it was on
sale and museums and stuff like this and
see if you can find a copy I'd love to
do that before I publish this but anyway
I wrote a book with a co-author Winifred
Rosen called from chocolate to morphine
about mind-altering drugs I think it's
an excellent book it's still in print
it's much loved many parents have given
it to their kids many kids have given it
to their parents it came out in 1983
just when the war on drugs started which
was precipitated by the death of a
basketball player Len Bias and that
started the Reagan's and a whole crusade
so that book caused a lot of controversy
because it did not say no it's it said
if you're good we're not going to tell
you whether you should use drugs or not
but if you are this is what you should
know about them and these are the
precautions that you might take and it
went through all drugs the legal ones
nicotine and all the forms of caffeine
you know all the psychedelic stimulants
down there so forth
so a senator Republican senator from
Florida Paula Hawkins who was a crony of
Nancy Reagan's made it a campaign to get
the book banned and she stood up on the
floor of the Senate waving the book
around it was on national news which got
more publicity than the publisher got
for it and there then followed a
campaign to ban that book from libraries
that there was a personal campaign to
try to keep me from speaking in places
that was organized by the White House
very interesting times anyway I'm still
here the book is still in print and very
popular and you know I recommend that
it's great what were there any
particular actually let me take take a
step back for people who are listening
to that experience and looking back at
some of the blowback that was
experienced in the let's just call it
the the Leary era and wondering if there
are things that can be done to minimize
the likelihood of or just mitigate
excessive blowback to current research
and attempts to reclassify things like
MDMA psilocybin and so on for very
legitimate medical applications did you
have any thoughts on kind of best
practices for people who are very
enthusiastic I'm just Minh in this world
for so much longer than most I don't
know if you have any any particular
thoughts on how to not unnecessarily
jeopardize things I guess is uh okay
first first of all don't be angry
because I I see many people out there
who talk about subjects and get
tremendous blowback and think that
people are reacting to the content of
what they're saying and it's not it's
the tone of what they're saying right
I've gotten away with saying the most
outrageous things because I'm not angry
and people listen and we can have actual
dialogue secondly I think it's very
important to suggest possibilities for
uses of these agents for which we don't
have that address problems for which we
don't have solutions for example
the opioid crisis is a fantastic
opportunity at the moment both for
integrative medicine in general and for
cannabis medicine you know doctors
working in states where cannabis is
legal say that it has tremendously
improved the lives of patients who are
depend on the opioids and and
tremendously improve their lives as
practitioners who are faced with how to
deal with chronic pain management so
that's one area that I think is very
important so the demonstration that
psilocybin for example is can be used
with obsessive-compulsive disorder that
MDMA produces these tremendous results
with post-traumatic stress disorder you
know this is all helping greatly to
legitimize the uses of these and let's
talk about that this is something that
we could we could talk about for hours
and days and weeks probably but just for
the sake of of definition could you
define for people integrative medicine
the the combination of these two sure
first of all I think this is medicine of
the future and the term integrative
medicine is now totally accepted in
academic discourse there are textbooks
of Integrative Medicine you know all
medical journals refer to it so the
short answer is it's the intelligent
combination of conventional medicine and
natural and preventive medicine and
useful alternative therapies the longer
answer is that it's a system that
emphasizes the natural healing power of
the organism that looks at people not
just as physical bodies but also as
mental emotional being spiritual
entities community members that's
sometimes called whole person medicine
that place is a great deal of emphasis
on lifestyle and all of the lifestyle
factors that influence health and
illness that really values the
practitioner patient relationship and
makes use of all available therapies
that show reasonable evidence of
efficacy and aren't going to cause harm
and we often butt heads against the
evidence-based medicine people who say
we're trying to advocate unscientific
anti-scientific ideas and practices you
know my feeling has always been that a
good way to use evidence a good rule to
follow is that the greater the potential
of a treatment to cause harm the
stricter the standards of evidence it
should be held to for efficacy if we had
follow that principle and standard
medicine we'd save ourselves a lot of
trouble I often teach patients commonly
teach patients breathing techniques
there hasn't been a lot of research on
the health effects of breathing because
nobody takes it seriously it doesn't
involve a drug or a device but the
chance of these breathing techniques
causing harm is so negligible that I'm
not bothered by recommending him the
absence of a great deal of evidence for
them anyway integrative medicine is the
future I found it and direct center of
excellence at the University of Arizona
College of Medicine the Center for
Integrative Medicine where the world
leader in educating physicians in this
new system so we give two-year thousand
hour fellowships for MDS and dioz that
teach nutrition mind-body interactions
herbal medicine including uses of
cannabis and psychedelics these
strengths and weaknesses of alternative
medical systems spirituality and
medicine you know all these things that
are left out of conventional training
and we've now graduated about 1,600
physicians from that intensive
fellowship there in practice all over
the country and in many other countries
we have our curriculum and 80
residency's throughout the country we
teach medical students we're about to
open an integrative primary care clinic
and Tucson so we're really on a roll and
as I say I think this is the future
because the great promise of Integrative
Medicine is that it can lower healthcare
costs while maintaining or I think
improving health outcomes and I think
it's the only way out of this mess that
we have with healthcare in this country
so there's a lot to dig into here and
yet I'm looking forward to it so you
have just four people who may have
missed this earlier but they must have
been smoking something of their own if
they missed it earlier you do have
experience with and familiarity with
double-blind placebo-controlled stuff
and their I don't I don't think and
correct me if I'm wrong that you would
argue that there is no place for that
and and and that it has a place it is a
source of information there either one
kind of information right and it has its
own limitations I think there are other
kinds of information that are valid for
example the information that comes from
your own experience and I like to point
out to people that in all languages
derived from Latin unfortunately not
English the word for experience and the
word for experiment are the same in
Spanish asafoetida and par means both to
experience and to experiment so your own
experience as a form of experimentation
that produces useful information you
have to check it against other kinds of
information with double-blind studies
you know this is held out it's the gold
standard and many people think this is
the only kind of information we should
pay attention to but here's an
interesting thing you can try this
yourself and it's assignment that I give
to medical students and doctors go into
a medical library and pull out any
medical journal that reports results of
placebo-controlled double-blind testing
turn to the you know pick an article
turn to the back of the article where
there's a summary that summarizing the
table summarizing the results in the
placebo group there will always be one
or two or a small number of subjects who
show all of the changes produced in the
experimental group who got the drug that
is fascinating I mean that means that
any change that we can produce in the
human organism by giving a
pharmacological agent can be exactly
mimicked in at least some people some of
the time purely by a mind mediated
mechanism the placebo response if you
want anyway we should be trying to take
advantage of that find out how to make
it happen more of the time also I would
just say that there are a great many
worthless and dangerous drugs on the
market at the moment
and many of them have a lot of placebo
controlled randomized trials behind them
no supporting their use so things can be
structured in ways to produce results
that people want
I want to spend some time on this
because I find myself and I think you
probably certainly not probably have
found yourself because straddling what
at times people perceive to be mutually
exclusive worlds so I have on one hand a
lot of interaction with you name it
right clinical psychologists and
different researchers at UCSF at Johns
Hopkins at many different institutions
where I'm funding or helping to fund the
the types of studies that we're talking
about and then on the other hand I
experiment with a lot of what people
would consider esoteric and probably
just outright crazy stuff some of it
below the border not all of it below the
border and I would love to hear since
you've spoken you've spoken I think
quite quite a bit about some of the
limitations of the types of studies
we're talking about among others we
haven't even talked about but that that
these are not necessarily the first
place to go if you're looking to
generate hypotheses that are innovative
for testing in the first place but if we
were to flip the coin and look at the
other side because you mentioned tone
earlier and how a lot can be dismissed
if you are angry and you you it's it's
not a response to the content but it's
it's a response to the tone where do
people in the integrative medicine field
or in the complementary or alternative
treatment realms make mistakes like
where what are some of the ways in which
they think they have all the answers or
alienate themselves from people who
might actually be open with a different
delivery to some of what they're
experimenting with well with the the
people that I come in contact with who
come through our training programs I
always emphasize this not being angry
and to have some published data to
support things that you're doing with
patients so that somebody asks you know
why you're getting this treatment you
can cite something so I think to me
that's most
I don't see many people today I mean the
common mistake is just to antagonize
colleagues or to reject conventional
medicine out of hand I you know a
primary I don't like the term
alternative medicine it suggests that
you're trying to replace conventional
medicine and that's not my goal I want
to make conventional medicine better and
and you know knowing when and when not
to use that system is extremely
important I said earlier drawing on your
own experience four hypotheses let me
give you two personal experiences of
mine that suggest possibilities that I
would love to see tested in research
settings at this about that same time
that I had that experience with yoga and
LSD on another occasion I took LSD also
in a wonderful outdoor setting feeling
great I had a lifelong allergy to cats
this is again when I was 28 if a cat
came near me my eyes would itch and I my
nose would run and if a cat licked me
I'd get hives where it licked me so I
always you know tended to avoid them so
on this day when I was high on LSD
feeling great a cat came up and jumped
in my lap and I had a moment's like you
know trying myself against it and then I
thought it's a silly you know I'm just
gonna drop this and I began petting the
cat and enjoying it I had no allergic
reaction and I never had one sense so
instant disappearance of allergies
alright so how about you offer allergy
treatment centers where people come in
and then the first visit they take a
full dose of the substance and then over
say ten visits you've reduced the dose
until the end they're taking nothing and
they've learn to unlearn the allergy
also around the same time another
dramatic physical change in me I grew up
I was told I had very fair skin I could
never get tan and we used to go down to
the Jersey Shore in the summer and
beaches I can't tell you how many times
you know I sheets of skin peeling off
you know horrible and then I'd never you
know never get tan so that's I just
accepted that so also around the same
time when I was doing almost
experimentation and I think this is
again with LSD
doors running around naked in the Sun
and I was lying down looking at the Sun
and I thought this is silly I mean at
the Sun is not my aunt enemy I got tan
the next day and I have ever since now
these kinds of changes I have not seen
much written about and to me that's
that's the stuff I would love to see
tested I'd love to see us figure out you
know these potentials and how they allow
more people to experience them and this
is why I say that when you're dealing
with people with chronic illness whether
it's chronic pain or autoimmunity where
they don't see a possibility of changing
it you can I think arrange conditions of
set and setting with the right agent in
which you can show people that it's
possible to experience your body in a
different way do you do you recall how
many roughly micrograms you were
consuming with the cat allergy
experience oh my guess is with some
somewhere around you know maybe 200
something like that I've got it and how
would you if you had to
how would you attempt to explain that
like what do you do you have a
hypothetical mechanism or energy thing
is easier to explain than the reaction
because there's obviously a mind-body
component of allergy you can show if a
person has an allergy to roses you can
show them a plastic rose and we'll have
allergic symptoms for example I think
many people with allergies can see that
changing emotional states really affect
the allergic expression so that to me is
more understandable although the fact
that it was a permanent change I find
very interesting with tanning I mean
that's a little more complex the
physiology of that so I haven't thought
about that I'm sure there is a fizzy you
know physiological mechanism underlying
it but it again suggests that many
aspects of our reaction to the
environment are modifiable by changing
our internal state
and you mentioned Bree I want to come
back to breathing since that seems to
also tie into this as you mentioned and
I think you've also discussed publicly
having this this sliding scale of
evidence it in the sense that the the
more something has the potential and a
demonstrated potential for harm the
greater the burden of proof should be
and you know that hormone replacement
therapy and I mean there are many
examples that come to mind that seem to
be a great idea at the time
with certain populations which
demonstrably could have been predicted
to have known dangers the in the case of
breathing right compared to benzos and
all these other drugs that are available
what is there a sample breathing
technique you could describe for people
who are looking at you reduce anxiety
there's a breath that I teach which I
learned from dr. Fulford that I call the
478 breath and if people will just
google my name and four seven eight
breath you'll get demonstrations of me
doing it it's all over the place these
days but basically it's it's a yoga
technique you let all the air out
through your mouth and you breathe in
quietly through your nose to account of
for hold your breath for a count of
seven blow air out your mouth forcibly
to a count of eight and you repeat that
for four breath cycles you got to do it
at least twice a day it's a practice and
by doing this you change the tone of the
autonomic nervous system you decrease
sympathetic tone increase
parasympathetic tone the relaxation
responds that after practicing this for
you know several weeks months it becomes
an amazing tool for all sorts of things
one is controlling anxiety lowering
blood pressure heart rate improving
digestion and so forth and breath is
really it's the key to controlling
involuntary functions and the in breath
is breathing is the only thing you can
do completely consciously or completely
unconsciously
the theory is that by using your
voluntary system to impose rhythms on
the breath gradually those
reduced in the involuntary nervous
system which you can't get at directly
so I've seen tremendous results of
people doing this for 7/8 breath
practice just amazing thing stopping
atrial fibrillation having cold hands
become warm chronic digestive problems
disappearing but for anxiety
it is far and away the best method I've
ever found that makes benzodiazepines
look very pathetic by comparison and
I've seen even the most extreme cases of
panic - so were to respond to this
breathing technique once people
practiced it enough you you have a
history of spotting or end or
popularizing concepts terms even fields
of study long before they hit the
mainstream if right now we're we're
edging into some territory that that
might lead into this for instance and
then the question is going to be what
what what current accepted concepts or
practices do you think are going to be
obsolete in the near future or
significantly revised right because we
have we have might this like Cartesian
mind-body separation which to me is
hilarious also because it's it tends to
overlap almost perfectly with people who
have a sort of a hyper materialist view
of brain brain equals mind it's just
very hard to reconcile like since it's
an organ but the the the the reason this
came to mind for me is you mentioned
autonomous nervous system right and
these are things that I suppose most
would assume you do not have any
conscious control over and yet I've
spent time as an example and no I
haven't seen this studied in a clinical
setting because who the hell would
actually do it and study it and who
would want to put their career on hold
or for two or three years to do it but
there's a a professor formerly from
Stanford Medical School life lifelong
meditator uses neurofeedback very
consistently and he can do some very
strange things I've seen him do this
multiple times where you can pick one of
his eyes and he can hyper dilate
his pupil in the eye that you choose you
can watch this happen it is one of the
strangest things I have seen so that
that's a long-winded way of asking a
question but what are what are certain
concepts or beliefs held to be true or
things that are held in strong
conviction now in medicine or or
tangentially related to it that you
think are going to be significantly
revised well first let me tell you two
quick stories it's relevant to this I
grew up in Philadelphia late 1940s 1950s
all shoe stores had flora scopes in them
these were big consoles and to check the
fit of shoes so you went in as a kid the
salesman got you shoes and then you
would go to this fluoroscope stick your
feet under it and there was a viewing
thing you could look into and you'd see
the bones of your feet this big glowing
green screen and the shoe salesman would
point out to your parents how well the
shoes fit and as a kid your job was to
distract the shoe salesman and your
parents so you could spend as much time
under there as possible I mean
unbelievable flora scopes in shoe stores
what were they thinking going back a
little earlier I when I was at Harvard
Medical School I found this old attic of
medical curiosities and one item in
theirs was from about the turn of the
you know early 1900s was a belt
with two pouches that held radium or
that was supposed to be worn around the
waist the palace today pouches fit over
the kidneys to deliver healthful
radiation to your kidneys for several
hours a day now whatever I see things
like that I wonder what are we doing now
back at fifty years from now and not
believe that we did I'll tell you one
area's dentistry I think the whole the
whole idea of drilling cavities and
filling them with foreign materials I
think that's we will not believe that we
were doing that I really think that
chemotherapy and radiation will be
obsolete as cancer treatments probably
in not-too-distant future and you know
the problem with those is they just
don't distinguish well and off between
malignant cells and normal cells unless
you're dealing with a cancer it has a
very rapid cell division rate which you
know most of them don't
I think that'll be replaced by things
like gene therapy and immunotherapy
anti-angiogenesis therapy so forth I
think the whole field of regenerative
medicine is right on the horizon this
recent research that was done in the
pain of being able to take pills from
skin and get them to reverse to an
embryonic state where they can
differentiate into any line I mean this
we're really close to being able to
regenerate organs spinal cord injuries
damaged hearts I think that's all in the
horizon and will replace a lot of the
things that we have now I think a lot of
the diseases that we consider incurable
that's just you know a concept that we
have and and once you see it's possible
then it's possible and if it's possible
in one individual why it shouldn't it be
possible for everyone see you've talked
about certainly I think it was through a
quote maybe as full as a Fulford am i
getting the right the full you know
Fulford but related to the body healing
itself right and the for people who are
interested this wasn't mention also in
the meantime as it relates to cancer
there's some very interesting work being
done looking at the impact of fasting
mm-hmm when combined combined typically
pretreatment with different types of
chemotherapy and radiation and from a
anecdotal perspective I can I can
certainly vouch for the protective
effects of not related to normal cells
of fasting with a friend who is part of
a cohort this group of people who are
going through these very intense
treatments for a later stage cancer that
he had and those who did not fast in his
group they were there were a few
experimenting with fasting and sure you
could explain this away in a number of
different ways but the people who did
not fast were laid out four days
afterwards basically on the couch not
moving and he and a few others were
going for five ten mile training runs
the next morning it's really fascinating
stuff the the dentistry that you
mentioned you talked about some of the
potential
replacements that that that are
certainly being explored quite a bit now
related to cancer with dentistry what
would you see replacing the current
approach to drilling and filling one
possibility is a vaccine that would
inoculate you against the bacteria that
cause decay you know that's one thing I
think it's an also a place for
regenerative medicine that possibly
being able to stimulate the growth of
new teeth I think that's all within the
realm of possibility mm-hmm and there
are this is probably not specifically
intended to help people regenerate teeth
but there are services now which may be
outdated shortly but for people who are
curious where you can you can take the
baby teeth as they are supposed to
discard it I'm not sure if the proper
word is released from the mouth by your
children and then have them immediately
shipped for storage so you can harvest
the the pulp the stem cell pulp later
for regenerative uses there are eight I
didn't know about that that's neat it's
pretty cool yeah there are services that
do that so you don't necessarily have to
drill into your kids hip or it might be
which is of course part of the part of
the of what makes the the research in
Japan and so on so exciting the the
possibility of getting to the kind of
embryonic starting point without having
to use these really invasive procedures
what else you most excited about right
now well I have to say that the
mainstreaming of Integrative Medicine
thrills me you know I've been writing
and saying the same things about medical
education medicine health for probably
45 years and in the early years nobody
paid attention to me and then I got a
larger and larger following in the
general public but none of my medical
colleagues took me seriously
and that didn't change until the early
1990s and it was then when the the
economics of health care began to go
south
that institutions began to open to this
and one lesson I draw from that is that
no amount of ideological argument moves
anything it's only when the pocketbooks
of institutions get squeezed enough that
they begin to open to change but the
change is quite remarkable you know
there's a group called the consortium of
academic health centers for Integrative
Medicine and now two-thirds of the
medical schools in the US have joined
this and this requires the Dean or
Chancellor of institution has to request
membership and the school has to show
that they've got activity in two of the
three areas of clinical medicine
research and teaching so it's quite
wonderful to watch this happen hmm what
there's I mean we could talk for hours
and hours and hours and we definitely
have to hang out again and maybe we can
go for a hike with our mutual friends
certainly if I'm long enough Paul Paul
Stamets yeah just be amazing what books
have you gifted the most to other people
outside of your own books are there any
books that you've gifted often to other
people yes one is a translation of Lao
Tzu by a man named Witter binner it's
called the way of life according to
allow so that's beautiful translations
and I find those you know verses which
was the sole output of this philosopher
to be you know remarkably right on I I
another book that you know now a lot
recently is we by Robert Johnson a
Jungian psychoanalyst it's subtitled the
psychology of romantic love a very short
easily read book about the traps that
people get themselves into in romantic
relationships and that's one that I I
like very much Jesus I have a whole
bunch out there what what catalyst or
let you do to gift we just because I see
so many my friends who are trapped in
repetitive patterns with other people
that are very unfulfilling and
I know we is all about how we project
something onto another person which
really is inside us and that totally
fits with my ideas about drug highs and
healing that these are all within us and
we sometime need something external on
which to project our our belief in order
to experience what we want to experience
on that note I've heard you talk about
the the drive to experience um I don't
use that that non-ordinary states of
consciousness to be in innate to human
beings right they you know that was the
premise of my first book the natural
mind that we haven't an innate drive to
alter consciousness not necessarily with
drugs there's also ways of doing it sure
children I thought about you were swings
yes children spinning around and so
forth that also got me in a lot of
trouble when that was first first
published you know people didn't want to
hear that but I think this is absolutely
the case and it's in all societies and I
think the inability of our society to
allow for for that drive and to help
channel it in good directions is one
reason why we have the kind of drug
problems we do today so I think teaching
people how to experience these states
how to get them in ways that are
manageable and will hold up for you over
time we should be doing that and the
people who to be teaching that are
people who have mastered that themselves
whether it you know the the equivalents
of shamans in our society when you look
at periods in your life where you feel
like you're in the zone however you
would define that what are some of the
daily or weekly practices that you that
you spot just in terms of the pattern
recognition when you look back at these
sweet spots when you've just really been
performing and feeling performing well
and feeling good are there any
particular daily weekly practices
morning habits whatever comes to mind
that the UC is consistent well I I do
have a sitting meditation practice
sometimes quite brief but I do it when I
first get up in the morning and and I've
done that quite regularly for a long
time part of that is my breathing work
another is being physically active in
the forms of my physical activity have
changed over my lifetime in my 20s I ran
and I got signals from my knees that
they didn't like that and I started
biking instead I always did a lot of
walking and hiking in in later life I've
really gotten into swimming I mean
that's my favorite physical activity at
the moment
I've lived with dogs for most of my
adult life and I can't imagine life
without dogs and that has been a very
important part of my emotional
well-being nights we would say my
connection with plants which we started
out talking about brings me a great deal
of fulfillment but growing plants using
them as medicine cooking cooking and
food preparation have always been very
grounding for me I've often said and
written that for me cooking is a
meditation chopping vegetables also
manifesting I have a concept in my head
something that I want to prepare I think
cooking is great training and practical
magic you know how do you manifest
things how do you think things from
inside your head and make them real and
physical reality as close to your
imagination as possible and to be
cooking is the great for doing that so
that's been very important to me and I
love I love turning people on to new
experiences including experiences of
food and plants a lot of people over the
years have said to me that reading and
reading my books that I've put into
words things that they always knew to be
true but hadn't put words into words
themselves that makes me very happy I
have many people come up to me you say
that reading my books or taking our
training programs has really changed
their lives for the
better that makes me very happy it makes
me feel I'm doing what I'm supposed to
be doing do you I don't know what your
current troop looks like but do you
still have your wanna say rhodesian
Ridgebacks I have to rhodesian
Ridgebacks a male and a female who or is
my third generation of them and their
stellar they've also you know for me
living with them has really taught me to
be good at nonverbal communication you
know we're really good at reading each
other's needs and once and intentions
and that that's been remarkable training
there's been also some you probably have
seen some of us research on some of the
positive interactions with dogs
especially one is that dogs are the only
animal that hold our gaze in most
animals regard looking into the eyes as
a threat and dogs have evolved the
ability to hold their gaze and there's
research showing that when a dog holds
your gaze there is oxytocin released
both in the dog's brain and the human
brain and the longer the eye connection
is the greater the release of oxytocin
which is the bonding hormone the results
of a paper that came out in this past
year showing that when you exchange
saliva with a dog
I won't I won't wait the hell that
happens but it happens that this does
very good things for your microbiome and
in particular it changes it in ways that
seem to protect against obesity I cannot
wait to see the products to come out in
a comment the dog saliva morning swish
the the morning meditation could could
you elaborate on that just a second in
terms of the the format like when you
see what does that look like in
probation I first you know I long long
ago around the time that I was writing
the natural minor became interested in
meditation I began reading about Zen I
met people who practiced in so that's
what I first tried of sitting down
counting breaths then I took some the
possum the training mindfulness
meditation and so what I do now is a
kind of combination of that I sit down I
first do my breathing I do some bellows
breath Breath of Fire and then I do that
for seven eight breath
for at least eight breath cycles and
then I try to keep my attention on my
breath on sensations in my body on a you
know whatever's actuals sensory signals
in the room around me and if I'm aware
that my attention is in my thoughts or
on images I just try to bring it back to
those things so that's really all that I
do and you know a simple sitting but to
me meditation is not about doing it just
in a special time of sitting it's
carrying that experience in training
into all aspects of your life so whether
it's driving walking chopping vegetables
you want to be as much in that state as
possible to me that's the essence of
mindfulness and you mentioned the pasta
you may have or you may have other
recommendations which I'd love to hear
but for people who are curious about
experimenting with a pasta in a way that
does not involve a whole ton of language
that perhaps they don't speak natively
we mentor we using the Royal we
I mentioned Sam Harris earlier his
waking up app I find it to be very very
very good for this particularly if
people have previously had an allergy to
how it's how can somehow sometimes be
presented the I'm a great I'm a great
admirer of his work and another one of
the books that I have commonly given out
to people is the end of face now you
know it's it's very slim little volume
and III he the the combination of being
a neuroscientist you know somebody who
really questions religious dogma and
also accepts the mystery of existence I
think that's a very unusual combination
it is that is very unusual that yeah I
was thinking about your cooking remark
because I only in the last handful of
years discovered cooking in the process
of writing my third book and have often
wondered why I find cooking so
meditative as you put it
and one the one theory that I have is
that much like yi4 simply it is for
similar reasons that I find certain
types of sports and physical training
meditative and that is that there are
actually some consequences built-in like
you have to pay attention if you're
chopping if you're finally dicing
vegetables yeah yeah or you have three
things on different heats uh on the
stovetop but I was kicked out of the
kitchen growing up my mother said you
know I should be out playing but I was
always fascinated watching people do it
and I didn't I really got into it when I
was in medical school and I found you
know I in those days you have to work
really long shifts in hospitals and they
were ghastly places and when I came out
of them I I was in such bad mental and
emotional states and I found that
imagining something that I could cook
for myself and getting the ingredients
and then doing it that this put my head
back in a very good place so from a very
early time I discovered you know that
power of cooking for me and I've gotten
to be a very good home cook and over the
years many people said you ought open a
restaurant and I never was interested in
that because I know I knew nothing about
the restaurant business and it looked
like a very tough business and then
about 12 years ago a mutual friend
introduced me to a successful
restaurateur here in Arizona and I
proposed him the concept of a restaurant
that would serve delicious food that was
also healthy he his immediate response
was health food doesn't sell he so I
think he thought I was talking tofu and
sprouts I eventually asked him and his
wife to come out to my place I cooked
dinner for them they liked the food but
he was very skeptical and but his wheels
turned and he said he was willing to
give this a try but he was very doubtful
but we got a he got a piece of real
estate in Phoenix and which was a coffee
shop and we converted it and opened the
first true Food Kitchen 11 years ago it
was from the moment it opened an
immediate success a lot of my recipes
you know my
concept based on my anti-inflammatory
diet
it's delicious wonderful looking food it
also happens to adhere to good
nutritional guidelines and we now have
25 of these around the country very
success we're going to open 8 more this
year I'm still a minority owner in and
oversee the menu and that's been great
fun and watching people eat the kind of
food that I eat and loving it is great
it's it's there's a location here in
Austin true the kitchen about a few
blocks from where I'm sitting and
recording and I was actually there two
nights ago having dinner for those
people who might be interested that the
seasonal ingredient salad with chicken
added to it and with Dan angle who is
also a previous guest on the podcast so
I'm a fan why do you think given the
fatality rate and not just the fatality
rate but like the infant mortality rate
of restaurants and new concepts to what
do you attribute it being successful
from the get-go did you guys do a lot of
testing beforehand no we didn't know we
didn't I think my my partner Sam Fox his
taste in mind couldn't be more different
you know he likes cheeseburgers and
steaks and we butted heads over a lot of
things but he knows the restaurant
business so in our compromises I think
we worked out a formula that worked one
reason for the success is we have
something for everyone something for
meat-eaters vegetarians vegans
gluten-free people and we're willing to
modify recipes to whatever diners want
the the restaurant has created its its
own culture that's very distinctive and
it draws people to work there who lived
lifestyle the server's the cooks really
all follow the kind of lifestyle that
that I preach and that's visible when
you go into one of these places that the
III just can't tell you a lot of people
tell me that that people eat there four
and five times a week some of our dishes
like the kale salad have become so
popular we created a shortage of organic
kale on the west coast
years ago and I've had you know kids
come parents come up with kids and say
their kids favorite dish is the kale
salad they have to make it for him at
home I mean who would have ever thought
that American kids would be eating kale
salad so I think that there's the this
culture that's apparent when you go into
the restaurant we've had really no
successful competition and the food
speaks for itself it's it's beautiful
it's delicious flavors come through and
the fact that it makes you feel good
when you leave I think is you know what
draws people back so you know I was just
thinking as you mentioned the kale
shortage I was thinking for all the the
hedge fund managers listening to this
they should they should try to get
inside information on pending menu
additions yes they can go along whatever
that or if this look at the secondary
and tertiary effects of whatever the
shortage will be which is a real thing
almonds in California any case you met
so you mentioned True Food Kitchen this
this is a good this isn't this is a good
opportunity for me to ask you about
investments I mean you you've thought
about investing in many different ways
and I'd like to talk about investments
not of money but time energy and so on
is is can you think of one of or any of
the best or most worthwhile investments
you've ever made it could be money it
could be money in the sense that I've
had people on the podcast like Amelia
Boone who was an attorney but paid for
her first competitor ticket to world's
toughest Mudder she ended up being a
four time world champion and it really
changed your life so it could be it
could be money but not in the in the
strict sense of investment into a stock
or a a company if that makes sense
well one of them has to be true food
kitchen I was a I did invest money in it
by invested a great deal of time and the
reward that I've gotten back has been
many fold I've created a private
foundation the wael Foundation which
funds Integrative Medicine
education and research in this country
and other countries and been able to
give away seven million dollars in the
past few years since that was created
that's been very fulfilling to me in
terms of time investments I guess you
know I've invested an awful lot of time
in writing and that's not the easiest
occupation as you know but that has also
been incredibly rewarding to me you know
I publishing is a very uncertain
business these days and I was fortunate
enough to be in it at a time when you
know it worked and and to reap the
benefits of that and that's been very
satisfying but that's been a major part
of my life what about on the convert if
we look at the the other end of the
spectrum can you think of any failures
or apparent failures that set you up for
later success do you have any favorite
failures think about that or just things
you viewed as catastrophes or real awful
occurrences that turned out to be
blessings in disguise well you know for
a lot of years the kind of medicine that
I advocated people thought I was nuts
and you know no as I said none of my
medical colleagues took me seriously
they thought I'd gone off the deep end
so you know I I I knew that I was on the
right path and I've always had great
trust in my intuition and my you know
inner light and even in periods when I
did not get much confirmation of that
from the outside world I think I
developed the ability to just hold true
to what I knew knew to be right and keep
following my footsteps
are there any positions or opinions in
the last few years or at work could be
way back it doesn't have to be the last
few years that you've changed
substantially where you've shifted
shifted your position or completely
changed my life soon all the time and
you know I think that's that's one thing
that people respect about my work I'm
quite willing to say that I was wrong
about something or to as new information
comes out you mentioned though I do have
a very good ability to spot
trends and to pick up on things that may
take the mainstream culture years to
come around to and for example I was
warning people about trans fats probably
15 years before people saw how dangerous
they were and there was any attempt to
ban them from food so I'm just really
good at stuff like that how did that
come about
do you mind giving us a little bit of
background on how all right just I of
information comes across my desk and now
that I have you know all of these
students out there that I've trained you
know they constantly send me things I
don't have great patience to read whole
articles but I'm very good at getting
the gist of things very quickly and
putting together with other information
that I know and so you know what with or
with the anti-inflammatory diet ice I
saw this you know it must be again 15 18
years ago that there was this hypothesis
out there that chronic low level
inflammation may be the root cause of
many diseases that we had thought were
unrelated like heart disease and
Alzheimer's disease and cancer and I
picked up on that idea very early and
that led me to develop this
anti-inflammatory yeah eating plan
there's now a tremendous amount of
validation of that so all I can tell you
is I'm very intuitive about that I pick
up on things I see the connections to
other things and you know I'm willing to
start advocating them before the the
evidence is all there but most the time
the evidence comes in and you've been
there certain things you've done for a
long time like you mentioned the cooking
really beginning in if I'm remembering
correctly medical school you know in
recent memory it could be the last few
years last five years are there any new
beliefs or behaviors or habits that have
really improved the quality of your life
they come to mind
well I'm fascinated by the stuff that's
been out there on intermittent fasting
that's something that I've been
experimenting with I think the
biochemistry of it is fascinating I
think they're all different ways of
doing it I haven't figured out exactly
what's right for me but I'm sure there's
something there that's about
and I will continue to experiment with
that what else are there any resources
or particular people who led you to to
look into that closely I can't think of
one person I think it's been hearing
that from a variety of sources and and
reading the medical literature about it
mm-hmm so I but maybe a strange question
to ask you but I feel I feel like I want
to ask nonetheless it's not a scary
question but am i but it might be odd
which is when is the last time you
remember crying tears of joy this is a
question that was used as an but opener
at a group dinner once and I thought it
and I thought it was gonna completely
fall flat and could be a catastrophe
Mikel habb I want to give him credit and
it opened the portal to such a
incredible conversation among strangers
that I've jotted it down
I don't know that I've actually cried
tears of Joy's but I feel myself welling
up in certain circumstances and I think
a number of times when people have
written me or told me in person
that's something that I wrote or said
had really saved their life literally
and you know that's I just I have a very
strong emotional response to that is is
there anything that you besides looking
into intermittent fasting is there
anything in particular that you are
working on these days do you do anything
like new year's resolutions or do you
have any rituals around the new year no
first of all I don't believe in the new
year I think it's just an artificial
concept on a calendar if there is a you
know I was always fascinated by the fact
that the Jewish New Year is at the time
of the autumn equinox and it's not in
the first month of the Jewish calendar
so that's odd that the first the new
year begins not in the first months and
in some ways it's calling attention to
the importance of the autumn equinox and
I think that's a very special time you
know I think the image the symbolism
that I have there is that if you plant
root crops at that time
they develop in the dark they put roots
down you don't see any sign of them and
then the spring shoots come up and the
result of all that work in the dark
no manifests itself so the idea is that
at that time of year and that
equilibrated time of year that the
mental patterns the life patterns that
you set may manifest you know when
spring comes around so I sometimes at
that time if year I think about know
what I want to do but since I'm mostly
doing what I want to do I don't have to
change too much is your is the first say
60 minutes or 90 minutes of your day
fairly scripted at this point if so what
is it what is it what does it look when
do you wake up what does it look like
you know I I wake up pretty consistently
at 4:00 a.m. although it changes through
the you know I tend to wake up when it
gets light but my pattern now as I wake
up at 4:00 and I usually go to bed at
9:00 so I like to get seven hours of
sleep and I sleep with my dogs and if I
don't wake up at four the female dog
wakes me up exactly a four by licking my
head very vigorously anyway so I get up
I brush my teeth and then I sit down and
do my meditation however long that takes
and then I go in and I
I usually feed the dogs I may feed
myself and then as soon as it gets light
I take the dogs out there's a pretty
wild wash near my home and where they
run off leash fairly early in the
morning what what what are your default
breakfasts if you do have breakfast you
know I love Japanese breakfast and I
know you and I are both Japan oh files
I hate breakfast I hated breakfast
growing up as a kid there was nothing I
was served that I liked and I went to
Japan when I was 17 this was in 1959 I
was there with a student exchange group
I lived with Japanese families outside
of Tokyo and in Kobe and I suddenly
discovered this is what I want to eat
for breakfast you know that a piece of
broiled fish and miso soup and steamed
rice and some seaweed and pickles and
green
t-that just suits me fine and if I can I
have things like that for breakfast it's
got to be the best breakfast on the
planet I've tried so many breakfasts and
that's my favorite
and you've just sorted this make me feel
horrible and when I'm on the road that's
the meal I have most difficulty well by
the way let me also tell you another
story at that when I was first in Japan
it was I arrived and I think was
November 1st of 1959 was with this
family outside of Tokyo and or Arwa City
and there was no language in common
there was none of them spoke English I
didn't speak Japanese so there's a lot
of gesturing but on the second night
that I was there the mother of the
household took me next door to her
neighbor who was a practitioner of
Chinoy UT ceremony and I experienced a
tea ceremony for the first time and was
served matcha and two things about it
fascinated me one was the color of the
powdered tea I had never seen a more
beautiful green powder and the other was
the chocen this whisk that's made from
you know one piece of carved bamboo
that's just a miracle of carving and
something about the shape of that just
fascinated me it was used to whisk the
tea into a froth so as you can imagine
when I came back to the states in 1960
you know nobody knew about Japanese food
there was what every city had one
Japanese restaurant that was named Ginza
or Sakura and they had miso soup and
clear soup they had some tempura and
some kind of broiled salmon I mean the
idea of eating raw fish would no never
be there at all
and if anybody had told me that
Americans would be eating sushi the way
they are now I would never have believed
it so anyway I became a fan of matcha
from that time and that's another
example of something that I came across
and turned people onto many many years
before it became popular and in recent
years
I found a source really good matcha in
Japan in from eg with just the town
outside of Kyoto almost the tea growing
goes on and I've been making this
available to it I helped start a company
called
Machoke re the website is matcha calm
and it's just amazing to me to watch
matcha suddenly being discovered here
and I've seen it on you know it was a
recent episode of Madam Secretary were
order is preparing a bowl of matcha for
somebody I mean that's amazing so I was
I think 40 or 50 years ahead of that one
and matcha for those people wandering on
the spelling is ma TCH a matcha calm
that's a hell of a URL I know not bad
and Michael it literally means powdered
tea and this is the only form of tea in
which the whole leaf is consumed so
you're getting all of the nutrients
phytochemicals there and it's a
labor-intensive process of making it but
it's just it's a much as a beautiful
thing it is it is a fantastic tea I
consume much regularly I have some at
home and you can use the whisk if you
want to be sacrilegious but really
efficient you can also use one of those
battery powers for others I like iced
much also especially in warm weather and
I just put the matcha in cold water and
use one of the electric whisk to whisk
it then add ice to it I don't sweeten it
and it's again beautiful green and a
wonderful drink Green is my favorite
color and I'm a simple were to ask me
what shade of green I used to know the
exact Pantone number which is pretty
nerdy huh but it is it is it is they're
wanting the same really it's the color
of maple leaves in July on eastern Long
Island or when the sunlight hits the
back side or matcha rocky right like
that's so beautiful
let me ask just a few more questions and
then maybe we'll do a round two sometime
but okay I'd love to to break bread in
person then in the meantime at some
point but if you could have actually no
I'll start with a different one that I'm
gonna ask you that my usual what would
you put on a billboard question but
we'll get to that the in terms of small
purchases are there any purchases of say
$100 or less that have positively
impacted your life in recent memory
anything and it's specific people always
love specifics but is there any serves
little
yeah well one of them I'm holding in my
hand right now and my daughter turned me
on to these she's now 28 computer
glasses which I got on Amazon I know no
they were less than $20 but these are
yellow tinted glasses that enlarge
things slightly that has totally changed
my comfort in sitting in front of a
screen
you know it cancels out the blue light
and it just that's been a great thing to
have in my life
mm-hmm perfect so we're going from the
micro to the macro so we have the the
computer glasses and then something that
probably wouldn't require glasses which
is a gigantic billboard this is more of
a metaphorical question but if you could
get a message out to millions or
billions of people it could be a word
could be a sentence could be a quote
could be anything non-commercial what
might you put in it such a billboard I
think it's that you know it's all the
good stuff as inside you I mean that was
the main point of the natural mind is
that the highs that you get from drugs
are inside you they're in the nervous
system the drugs acts as a release er
healing is a potential inside you
various treatments or people can
activate that or release it but it's
that you know it's that everything
really is within and you don't have to
as as I'm not saying this for you I'm
saying this for people listening you
don't have to believe in witchcraft and
fairy dust to come to that conclusion if
you read the the article that I
mentioned I'll put it in the show notes
for everybody as well on the placebo
effect on how the placebo effect varies
culturally on how it's become stronger
in the United States on looking at the
outliers in the control groups these
placebo groups like you mentioned if
you're looking at the tables of studies
it's so exciting to explore and I am so
excited to see how it is further studied
and utilized in medicine because it's in
this is another one that I think I was
on too long before you know people got
into it if you I know whether you've
read my book called health and heal
that came out shortly after from
chocolate to morphine it was the first
book that I wrote on medicine and
medical philosophy there are two
chapters on that in that on placebos and
I would recommend go back and read them
because it's it's all this stuff that
we've been talking about medical
Nostradamus strikes again you know
Andrew people can find you at doctor
while calm medicine dot Arizona DD you
you're on Twitter at doctor while that's
WEEI al do you have any other or any
final asks or requests or suggestions
for people listening to the podcast just
in the process of finishing up no I
think you know my work is out there it's
easily accessed and I think it's
relevant to many people today and I
really enjoyed talking to you I it's
been a while since we work together in
person I hope we can remedy that yes
definitely well I guess you know there
might be more locations I won't food
kitchen popping up the very near future
and not not necessarily too far away
from either of us so perhaps we can we
can rendezvous at one of those or even
better if if I could sample some more
produce from your garden which was just
incredible and you know maybe we can
bring invite some bald eagles which was
also something I had never seen before
while we're after it that would be
they'll be really wonderful but I really
appreciate you taking the time I've been
wanting to have you on the podcast for
for quite a while so it's nice to
finally reconnect and certainly hope
it's it's not the last time any time
soon thanks for having me so thank you
and for everybody listening everything
we talked about the books the various
websites the macho you name it all of
those will be available in the show
notes as always at Tim de blanc forward
slash podcast so you can find links and
extended links to everything studies and
so on and
Andrew thank you again and you to
everybody listening be safe
experiment and experience widely use
your brains pay attention to your body
and until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
for me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday event provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to one getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens to try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a $100 value so if you buy
athletic greens you get an extra $100
and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
again that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by
audible audible provides an unbeatable
selection of audio books including
bestsellers how-to mysteries thrillers
memoirs and more I've used audible for
many years and I have a few audio books
to recommend right off the bat number
one ready player one by Ernest Cline so
listen to the book that caught the
attention of Spielberg enough to get
made into a major film the writing is
fantastic Tao Seneca my Seneca the
younger this is a collection of letters
my favorite compilation of letters of
all time that I've recommended the most
of all the books I've ever read and the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman this is
the fiction book that I use to convert
nonfiction purists into fiction lovers
I like the version that Neil reads
himself but that's just me he's a
hypnotic voice I also recently enjoyed
nonviolent communication by Marshall
Rosenberg which was recommended to me by
best-selling author and Neil Strauss
make sure to get the audiobook version
and you will recognize it by the peace
sign on the cover and as an audible
subscriber you can choose three titles
every month one audiobook and two
audible originals you can't hear
anywhere else and there's some really
really cool stuff among the audible
originals you can listen on any advice
anytime anywhere at home at the gym
while you're cooking on your commute or
wherever I often listen to audiobooks
when I'm walking my pooch or on the way
to the gym so on and so forth you'll
also enjoy easy audio book exchanges in
other words if you don't like what you
buy you know like buyer's remorse you
can swap it rollover credits so if you
don't use credits in a given month they
roll over into the next and an audiobook
library you keep forever even if you
cancel this last part is important
unlike say a streaming or rental service
with audible you own your books even if
you cancel your membership and right now
for a limited time you can get three
months of audible for just 695 a month
that's 6.95 a month and that is also
more than half off the regular price so
give yourself the gift of listening and
while you're at it think about giving
the gift of audible to someone
your list for more go to audible.com
forward slash tim t IM that is
audible.com forward slash tim or text
tim t IM - 500 500
you